der klimawandel und seine folgen stehen
derzeit im mittelpunkt politischer
debatten immer häufiger taucht dabei die
frage auf ob klimaveränderungen auch
gewaltsame konflikte hervorrufen
schon 2008 wurde etwa der krieg in
darfur im westen des sudan als klima
krieg bezeichnet heute in vechta kompakt
wie realistisch sind klimakriege die
auswirkungen des klimawandels werden
weltweit immer deutlicher spürbar
hitzewellen dürreperioden starkregen
überschwemmungen und der verlust von
trinkwasser werden vermehrt zu
überlebensfragen
das führt häufig zu spannungen und
gewalt zwischen betroffenen
bevölkerungsgruppen aber auch zwischen
staaten
der klimawandel gilt daher als konflikt
verstärker organisationen wie die uno
oder die oecd setzen sich schon seit
jahren mit den möglichen auswirkungen im
bereich sicherheit auseinander
bereits vor 15 jahren warnten experten
das amerikanische
verteidigungsministerium davor dass der
klimawandel eine der größten
kriegsgefahr darstellt welche konflikt
ursachen sind konkret anzusprechen
der kampf um rohstoffe um zum beispiel
den steigenden bedarf an erdöl und
seltenen erden zu decken werden
zunehmend neue flächen erschlossen
das kann rasch zu grenzstreitigkeiten
führen durch den rückgang des eises in
grönland könnte es in den nächsten
jahrzehnten zu einem kampf um die
wertvollen rohstoffe kommen
der anstieg des meeresspiegels das
bewirkt einerseits einen verlust an
anbauflächen und zwingt andererseits
küstenbewohner zum rückzug ins
landesinnere
der weltklimarat geht davon aus dass der
steigende meeresspiegel bis zum jahr
2100 an die 250 millionen menschen
zwingen wird ihren bisherigen lebensraum
aufzugeben
die ausbreitung der wüsten der damit
verbundene verlust dann beide land und
siedlungsfläche beschränkt den
lebensraum zusätzlich ein extreme
wetterphänomene
schon heute werden viele gegenden von
dürren überflutungen orkanen und
wurm heimgesucht dadurch werden häufig
ernten vernichtet und am bau sowie
siedlungsgebiete zerstört und
nahrungsmittelsicherheit das hungersnöte
oder nahrungsmittel engpässe zu
aufständen und revolten führen ist
hinlänglich bekannt
gerade die umbrüche in den arabischen
staaten 2011 sind jan zu führen
in tunesien ging es um den überhöhten
brotpreis der kriegsausbruch in syrien
wird mit dürren missernten sowie enormen
migrationsbewegungen in die städte in
zusammenhang gebracht wir steht nun
tatsächlich ein zusammenhang zwischen
konflikten und klimabedingten
umweltveränderungen ein
wissenschaftlicher nachweis ist
umstritten und wohl auch nur schwer zu
erbringen
das austrocknen von seen und die
verschiebung von regenzeiten führen per
se nicht zu konflikten aber damit
verbundene soziale folgen können
konfliktpotenziale verstärken
der klimawandel dürfte jene länder am
stärksten treffen die ohnehin eine
schwache wirtschaftliche entwicklung
aufweisen
eine veränderung des lokalen ökosystems
könnte sich zu konflikten aufschaukeln
die auch umfassende migrations und
fluchtbewegungen auslösen
die berufung auf umweltveränderungen
kann aber auch als vorwand für eigenes
versagen oder fehlende reformmaßnahmen
dienen
im extremfall können der
schuldzuweisungen an die
industriestaaten erfolgen
die als verursacher des klimawandels
gelten ressourcenmangel kann auch
genutzt werden um feindbilder zu
erzeugen
andererseits könnten sie starten aber
auch gezwungen sehen gemeinsam an einem
strang zu ziehen und konflikte zu
überwinden
womit es daher zu rechnen angesichts der
häufung extremer wetterphänomene in
bestimmten regionen wie der sahelzone
oder im mittleren osten und der zunahme
der bevölkerung in diesen räumen werden
konflikte wollen nicht ausbleiben
auch der wanderungsdruck wird erheblich
zunehmen viele wird es nach europa
ziehen möchte man daher
konfliktprävention betreiben und die
folgen des klimawandels abschwächen
so wird eine gesamtheitliche
herangehensweise nötig seien
diese reicht von der entwicklung von
flick szenarien über akute
problembewältigung bis zum nachhaltigen
engagement vor ort etwa im rahmen des
internationalen krisen und konflikte
managements und der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
wichtig dabei ist die erkenntnis dass
man umweltproblemen viel besser durch
gemeinsames handeln auf augenhöhe als
durch feindseligkeiten begegnen kann
ein ausblick der globale
gesinnungswandel die ja vor allem auf
druck der empörten jugend entstanden ist
könnte die wege für innovative ansätze
und gemeinsame lösungen erleichtern
die rasanten veränderungen lassen aber
vorerst erwarten dass
umweltveränderungen und
bevölkerungszunahme lokal und regional
spannung in bewirken und konflikte
eskalieren könnten
kriege die ausschließlich auf
klimaveränderungen beruhen zeichnet sich
allerdings nicht ab
sie sind aber ein bedeutender faktor für
konflikte und ein wesentlicher treiber
für migration